what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and we're back to
live streaming are we live streaming
yeah yeah this is live hi Auntie oh hi
yeah don't say anything you'll regret
because it will be on the internet
forever
this is your first life did you come
back yeah I'll do for honored like you
should be
awful blessing got it wrong when I saw
on air up there oh wow
is there anything that you should
what should we tell the people about our
time off we've been getting some stuff
done tell them
foreign
we just been um
cleaning house
cleaning cleaning that's the best for
cleaning the house cleaning no cleaning
house they know what I mean adults know
what I mean we've been cleaning now
um
um tell them about the cooking that
we've done what do we do for a wife's
school last episode oh you've done bread
I needed bread guys even though she
never heard the word need before but she
didn't even buy it I thought it was like
I'm needing you know I I I'm needing
some yeah yeah oh yeah we know what you
need to learn to need bread
and to knit apparently I'm gonna learn
to knit you get an internet that's what
you said you certainly no so so I played
the same thing to me no you tried
knitting that you know that that dress
that you got that I broke
she didn't break it it's just got a
spaghetti strap obviously weren't made
properly in the first place but it needs
tacking so we're gonna get our stitching
so today I decided I wanted to give you
an aneurysm
[Laughter]
these young people you know yeah is
there how do I say in the chat maybe
I'll see the um okay I'm gonna put the
chat on my phone just to make sure we
got
I just want to interact with you guys
send super chats also because blessing
what do you want blessing
you're trying to get something right
oh yeah someone stole a camera while we
were gone so we need to replace it
yeah oh you didn't know that did you
yeah shout out to whoever stole it why
did you steal mine you just don't mine I
know mine was sitting there my Sony if
you started my poker got me a better one
as a replacement idiots
I've been there for Mom City blessing my
Sony camera nobody lovely case and
everything I just I think it's like the
value of
don't lose it's about you I mean my
camera's vintage
foreign
yeah so you know we'd like to afford a
new camera for blessing to replace the
camera that someone stole
um yeah and if you see pearly in any
junk reporter to me please yeah I'm
blessing what do you mean eating all his
family at home
diet fruits vegetables organic stuff you
know gluten-free so every see I eat in
anything that you don't think she's
supposed to eat that's not full of
vitamins yeah minerals she's putting me
and me and blessing on a diet
yeah
what do you think of our diet disgusting
what's wrong disgusting it's not
balanced you don't eat no fruit no veg I
eat a lot of fruit you know I eat fruit
I eat fruit all the time
I don't vegetables no yeah
a lot of fruit yeah how much fruit has
you had today I'm not talking about the
little dinky thing the oranges I had
like two or clementines oh all day yeah
and the strawberries yeah I had the I
had one of those too a little tub but I
made yeah cut up fruit that's nice
you could ask my old roommate you could
ask my old roommate and when I lived in
Milwaukee I used to make these like
fruit salads my grandchildren had more
fruit than you before they went to
school this morning
one at one of them Clementine and one of
the Clementine and banana yeah and we
ate healthy and I had three common times
while I was just chilling okay I'm just
saying you said I eat no fruit I eat
some fruit not enough not enough fruit
not enough veg okay we're gonna all
right so today I decided I'm gonna give
you an aneurysm play the clip blessing
all right oh no
can you see that yeah we we can't hear
it though who are they
oh so there okay this couple is I've
seen that couple pop up somewhere
okay there so they're they're what they
call relationship goals
yeah
nothing now
no they are they are they're they're
writing a book on love no then isn't it
the one that told us a funny stinks no I
don't think so yes he did they said that
she smells no you're confused no he said
that a funny smells no they're they're
writing a book on love listen put it in
the chat right isn't that the man that
told her on a live chat and he says are
they outside she smells anything she
said you do smell is this gonna
copyright me
yeah we may not be able to play this
wait could I I'm gonna send a message to
Adam hold on
no
but I know I think I think we have to
record it though because I think it's
gonna pull down the live
oh
if I let me see if I can I'm gonna see
if I can bring him
no answer
what it didn't pull down the live
okay I just want to make sure how
well
okay fine we can all right anyway so
there are these two
I'm sure he totes of a coochie smells
okay these two are relationship goals
and they're writing a book on love
great I'm doing great she was a little
teary-eyed a little bit early I was
what's going on what happened what's
going on I don't know if it's my period
or am I pregnant I don't know
no sorry period I'm Pregnant come on if
you're bleeding no you're not up do I
think it's like before so she's either
gonna get her period or a baby either or
you know it's crazy you had a different
show she said she's been pregnant like
three times by him or something so she
don't know the difference by now
I don't know how long she's been having
a period it's actually that made a
difference no women they win women women
someone buzzing oh blessing I think the
dog you gotta yeah period or if you're
pregnant I'm just saying like that's
what's going on
well I don't think you're pregnant if
you got your period sweetie I'm just
saying I don't know if it's that or not
I mean I was just trying to help her out
here so you know I don't think it was
um what happened what triggered These
Tears
huh what triggered these tears what's
going on right now nothing
it could be like completely messing in
my eyes
so I got nothing to do anybody
what do you think about women that cry
over nothing
okay Batman emotional blackmail
it's emotional blackmail yeah okay can
we talked about something guys
I'm not even here for you
yeah we're here for you sweetie for real
we are so just speak up for us we hey
however you feeling today hopefully we
can get that out dominated I like his
voice
he sounds like so is it the Godfather
films that that Italian however you
think we have for you
2022 you're gonna get your flowers today
we gotta talk about it you know so I
like your song Too Vibes I was like I
ain't even know that was her ass I said
oh look at her she can rap too okay she
just don't know how to just fight and
take off on [__] she actually get out on
the music scale how's that been for you
like transitioning from obviously like
you know uh no name you know what I'm
saying like I'm just like Ray living
regular life to just all this this Fame
now and this I'm saying
this newfound stardom
how's it been for you how's the
transition been I just I give glory to
God
I swear to God huh God is good
that's why I didn't understand why
you're so sad I'm not sad
he was crying so I was like man what's
up yeah because just get emotional shows
you I'm emotional right now it's either
my period or I'm pregnant I don't know
I've gotten a lot of periods in my life
but I I could I could keep it together
for a podcast you know what I mean
auntie the way she's got her legs open
like that it can't be a period can't be
pregnant
maybe your legs are hurt you know from
being over there
yeah she's got a leg over him
you're saying you can't be pregnant and
put your leg over her maybe she's got
cramped because you wouldn't just cry
maybe he upset her before she come on
the show I've never been pregnant I
don't know I didn't cry
you know this conspiracy theories on the
internet that I have a kid and I'm like
hiding it
her name's Ellie I can I can confirm
that
and she's a [__] okay I can confirm
that she's a cute [__] yeah she's a
cute little Beauties now I behold of her
you know what they say adorable she's
adorable to my mom I mean she's got a
face that only a mother can love her
name is Ellie that is not true not true
that is Pearl's child Ellie the [__]
buy a dog and
Eddie the [__]
did you not hear me sir yo I did I just
I just know that you know a period in
pregnancy don't run hand in hand I'm
saying he's either am I tripping can I
hear me
she means like either that or yeah
next week gonna be my emotional week
okay it's on the way I'm I'm under the
impression that it was going on right
now she was like it's either my period
or I'm pregnant yeah
it's gonna come or it's not gonna come
yeah yeah well congratulations if it
doesn't come
October
she crazy
it is her
because he was treating her bad he
bought other tooth and then he left him
and she because she was getting all
above herself because she had the
missing tooth that some girl knocked out
because of him right and then well I'm
telling I know something about the young
people that you don't know and she took
out the tooth on social media to prove
her love for him that's why she's got
the big old gap in her mouth
anyway now I've informed all you young
people
what do you think about them being
relationship goals I think they're sick
as hell I think do you know what with
the NADA and the other one that's who
they need to be joining up with yeah
they should all make videos together
because they ain't got a clue
are you excited for your video tonight
guys we're doing a show tonight Auntie's
gonna be on
who who's coming out with you it's an
Algerian Queen
I'm excited I'm excited oh hold on and
um King Rich's broth
put me into a rubbing the queen
they set me up but it won't happen again
it may happen again
what was that about crazy
televising it what's going on it's
happening is that the episode finale or
crazy in love I'm getting married in
October that's what I said I don't mind
coming to you know being the pastor and
seeing y'all huh I said I don't mind
coming you know actually this is man
what's up is it connected
okay this is my open
invitation to myself how do I put this I
would like to be invited to this wedding
and I would like to officiate I am a
registered Pastor in the state of
Illinois
um it's quite easy to get online I know
shocking
um but yeah I think I'd be a great
officiator so
if you guys want to get married and you
want me to officiate
I've always I've always I've also always
wanted to be a flower girl when I was a
kid it was
always the freaking I have these cousins
they're they're twins so who do you
think got the flower girl offers never
me never me no because you're too tall
I was kind of fat too oh well what can I
say
it was so fast
I would like to do it now that's all
nothing if never goes up past your
offense tonight's time for you to be a
bride
we reach High Reach for the Stars won't
be a flower girl we could be a bride
but you're gonna skip past boys mate
we're going straight to bride wait
I have Banner bridesmaid before
yeah but then then I was a bridesmaid
once but she stopped I'm actually not
friends with her anymore
what's that right you show up when you
become the bride
and signing it off man on the dotted
line for y'all man I think that'd be a
beautiful thing because at first I'm
gonna be real with y'all when I seen
this [__] I was like this gotta be for
play this got to be because they make
good money together that's how I looked
at it like people like seeing y'all
together people like seeing y'all
interact whether it's drama whether it's
just kicking it whether it's just y'all
too [__] just sitting there and
just looking at each other not saying
nothing people like seeing y'all
together you know what I'm saying so I
just I I didn't know until like I seen
like okay they really do [__] with each
other yeah for sure like I was telling
you last time I was like damn I thought
it was just I thought it was just a sham
I said [__] I just making money get your
bread right but then I start seeing
y'all really do love each other and I
see you even when it's not about the
money okay
it's what they call toxic Love Now isn't
it that's good yeah I'm learning toxic
love I mean you know how many songs are
about toxic love
now I know about the drunken loved one
and I know she's always drunk and then
Matt's all about tough okay it's like
it's like that one Rihanna song about he
beat he beats me black and blue but he
he's so good and I can't get enough of
my speed love on the brain you know
goofy I'm not Ariana fan yeah it's like
it's like that was I think that was
about Chris Brown maybe I don't know I
like Chris Brown I love the money but of
course not I get it what is it about
what's keeping you guys together love
you think because I've been in this
before I [__] with people where maybe
it's a traumatic bond that brought you
all together maybe it was something that
happened that was very big that only
y'all two understand
if that makes any sense traumatic bonds
can bring people together too so like
traumatically like [__] being [__] up
yeah no just having a [__] up
situation you having a [__] up
situation where it don't have to be
financially you know what I'm saying it
can just be something mentally mentally
something going on that bonded y'all and
that's what I would consider almost a
dramatically bring people together
I don't think it's I don't think it's
traumatic I think it's um yeah I don't
think that either only if we fight each
other
they're always fine it's more of a
I don't know I guess like an underground
thing like when I met her she was
underground right you know so
underground her getting that's a good
way to put it yeah her getting to this
point that was a good way to put it for
sure it was an underground relationship
so from starting with that it's kind of
like each day that we keep going it's
like so what do you mean by underground
underground as in like yeah like um what
are you talking about like secret can I
get a shot no no no not secret more
underground is kind of like
undiscovered you know unappreciated
disliked
um
not ideal hang a minute she might be
pregnant first of all she said that
she's drunk Nancy's asking for a shot
and that's the girl that before he even
committed to her she has I think she's
got a his picture titled on her neck
no ring they weren't even together no
they weren't together they weren't even
together and she went and got it
tattooed on her neck and they weren't
they weren't like official but she
allegedly aborted three of his children
why would you get a tattoo but you won't
carry the man's child but you can carry
his big old face on your neck
and no wonder because she's always drunk
she said that she might be pregnant and
she won't she's saying to the person
give me another shot I don't understand
people have like no self-control
I just yeah some people like that
regarding sugar and vegetables
somebody have no self-control when it
comes to God oh my gosh
is
getting drunk on a podcast listen right
discipline is discipline if she was fat
you say the same thing you know fat
alcohol
sugar I work out I work out
maybe maybe I'll go like a week without
sugar you think I could do it no
no
I'll do it all right then starting not
today
yeah exactly not really what you would
apply yeah so it started as that from
the very beginning so it's kind of like
all right if everybody I was always
against y'all exactly so it's like if
the odds is against us obviously we're
gonna have a a natural bond just from
being underdogs how do you guys feel
about the um Whitney and Bobby
or I contain a comparison I mean
personally yeah I never really I don't
know I don't really know too much about
this story so I couldn't even tell you
if it was similar or not but from what I
do know we don't have like anything
[Music]
I'm feeding her anything to keep her
going or anything honestly so you say
she's not giving me
I'll call them either drugs
that's what I gotta say used to yeah no
no this is just really this is naturally
fried right right
now from what I know from their
situation is kind of drug based right
Whitney Houston I continue yeah well
that's why the comparison is so far
because it's kind of it's kind of saying
that oh these are two crackheads
well you don't look like no crackheads
yeah no not at all
why does it happen what does a crackhead
look like I mean
I haven't been around a lot of
crackheads so maybe I'm wrong I mean
there's the ones that like live around
here clearly
but Christina yeah you know um but
what does a cricket look like they go is
it the same way how you kind of
functional alcoholics I reckon that you
can have functional cracks yeah it's
like crackheads yeah maybe yeah they
don't look like crackheads they look
like functional crackers I know some
doctors I've submit doctors and nurses
black records
oh wow I know and it's you'd be
surprised at how many of them are out
there what we do is drinking smokes
y'all act like anything yeah I know I
know some smoke that was some drug
addicts I was about to say I know some
drug addicts y'all don't act like me
yeah no not at all so I mean but the
comparison is
I can see the comparison I guess it's an
ideal couple that people don't really
approve approve of or agree with so I
guess we love watching [__] that they
don't right
you actually just tweeted something
about that they love to keep talking
[__] they don't like yeah yeah about the
truth you just tweeted that there are
people who voted for us what was a tweet
I said I love when I spot a [__]
who said me and rock doing the show is a
bad idea but they're watching full
circle like every episode they're
reporting on it they're promoting us who
have you spot it academics for sure let
y'all do something good though they
ain't gonna talk about you oh my gosh
this is the one thing all right I feel
like
sometimes sometimes people will say why
is everyone talking about us and like oh
and I'm like okay but because you're
doing crazy [__]
we're in entertainment of course we're
gonna
if you put yourself out there then
you're gonna know in it yeah you don't
you don't see me complaining it's like
you know people put themselves out there
doing weird stuff and then complain when
people comment about what they do or
don't do it in public then shut the door
and turn the camera off
you're and then they're like oh that's
like the jealousy and it's like nah he's
just a reality academics are just a he's
a reaction Channel
he's doing the same thing we're doing
reacting
I want to talk about your badge me and
her we've you know been in the the media
world today like me and her experience
that kind of like well I get dragged
every time I speak well on you guys yeah
[Music]
it's still a viral moment you know
whether you get dragged or not a Stiller
yeah it brings in customers so I see why
people do it you know obviously they got
to speak on the hottest topics at the
time so my shit's been organic though
bro like I didn't do it like to yeah you
keep the same personality like yeah like
I didn't do it like for views because I
know it's gonna be views I feel like
that's for y'all too like I don't think
y'all do it for views y'all do it really
for anything I think y'all [__]
just crazy together y'all just love each
other yeah we just have a lot of moments
that's all yeah we have a lot of moments
and um
see the thing about you is you kind of
like you want to stand on your initial
idea of it you know other podcast
interviewers
they're a dick ride you in the beginning
and then turn around I don't yeah I
don't want to sneak nobody yeah
so in the beginning it'll be like oh
that's the hardest hurt us out he's this
man speaking specifically aggressive
specifically at academics right now here
suck my dick to the to this [__]
come and then
later on fix his mouth after you suck my
dick fix his mouth to be like oh this is
not a good idea he must not have this he
must not have he's very and I'ma say
this academics
you know he's a very passive aggressive
type because he's done that to me he's
always done that too no jumper crew and
he always eat his words like I [__] with
sharp and I [__] with the whole crew but
then two minutes later he'd be like I
put my foot on all their chests yeah
like bruh what is you talking about man
like I said oh like that's I call that
passive
did you notice that she got the drink
and all the time she was asking for the
soda and I thought it was to I like
alcohol so that's why I spotted these
Clues
rather than mix it
she sweeps half of the straight alcohol
washed it down
with the soda and then pass him the
other half of the straight alcohol
only people that really want to get
drunk will do that and you can tell that
she's only drinking just to kill
whatever's going on in their mind
because that is the quickest way to get
drunk drink it straight and then because
you don't actually like the taste that's
why she's washing it down with the soda
right like you're you acting like you
cool [__] but you're really not yeah
you really don't [__] with what we're
doing you're waiting for your moment and
you're waiting for your moments you know
but I get it though everybody got a job
for sure everybody got a job man I guess
his is to be passive aggressive that's
what I call that like [__] like what
are you saying you're saying it without
trying to say it right you know so the
people want to know we all just watch
episode four of Crazy In Love
can we know what happened in the moment
that before the cameras arrived and
your head was bleeding
uh yeah so I mean it wasn't it wasn't
even though deep I'm gonna I'm gonna
just touch the surface like touch what
surface you know sometimes she has a day
where she's feeling like there you go
and her best and some days no don't even
touch the surface she's easily triggered
what
she's like Boston you wanna why are you
bossing him around let him talk
because they had this agreement that
they won't talk about their private
stuff but he's always saying it and she
always comes afterwards because she's
always pissed
that's why because when he said when he
told the world that a coochie Smalls she
said why do you have to answer that when
we're interacting because he said well
you know it's I was in it so it smells
what can I say the answer does it smell
and I just said well yeah I think they
just know you know when people know
which buttons are pushing each other to
get a reaction so he's pushing that yeah
that's why toxic is they both do it to
each other it's not just one-sided they
do it to each other
I'm gonna be talking
do you hear me talking yes or no all
right remember that version or not why
the [__] you want to embarrass me you
shouldn't be talking that's weird I
don't want to talk about it so what did
happen blue thank you
what do you mean uh so yeah so she was
having one she was having one of them
days where you know it's like an easy
easy fuse lit
and I was kind of we pulled up to the
house there was some white dude sitting
on the stairs so I'm [__] with him
like oh you look like this you look like
that you know just [__] with him
she took it upon herself to like trying
to like kind of defend him like why are
you being mean to him what are you
talking about I thought he was talking
about me and then I called you a [__]
let's answer that like think about it
don't you think that like okay my man
call me a [__] so why are you being a
[__] like why are you being a [__] you
gotta call me in [__] that's your man
okay that's weird that's your man I
swear it if he call me a [__] I just
feel like ladies aren't gonna
like if a dude spoke to me in a way that
I didn't like constantly I just wouldn't
be with him
that's what I said they're toxic yeah
it's just like why if you don't like the
way he talks to you or talks about you
in public why don't you just leave but
did you hear what you said to her
at the beginning
basically when I'm talking you shut up
otherwise I will embarrass you and she
knows that when he's talking
be quiet only one person speaks at a
time
[Music]
what happened in that moment why did you
call him a [__] because I felt like I
was played with and every time you feel
like he called me a [__]
oh gosh
so now she's mad because he started
talking about something she felt like he
shouldn't and that's how it always stops
and then
and then they just start to get madder
and then she's drunk as well so it
doesn't help you she started to slow her
words and then she just starts swearing
at everyone she's slowing her words
she's like a kid they're both kids yeah
okay cool like if you could call me a
[__] I could call you a [__] back
straight up whatever you don't feel that
way so we fought
that's that like what
did you learn anything from me what do
you mean learn anything from me other
than getting a fight what do you mean
learn anything from it by coming
together with your man and saying you
know what baby we're not gonna be on
that anymore because I really do [__]
with you and respect you church I don't
know if she really do
you know what I was thinking about
huh
they can both vote
that is that their vote counts just as
much as yours or mine well I guess
you're British so yeah
power America with that point if she
gonna roll her eyes out bro she's well
she's very if you're caught a [__] I
should be able to call you and yeah I
could be able to clock your [__] back
but just because it's a double standard
thing I think that's unfair don't talk
to me about the unfair [__] we heard
that don't talk to me about the double
standard [__] you let them talk I'm done
I always say this well hold up I want to
hear what Gina Brothers
make a comment the perception is the
perception is just different just
because of how much we've seen you be
the aggressor so much so that's why
people is looking at it I see like the
aggressor that's why people is looking
at it like you're just instantly the one
that's the disrespectful one because of
what people see
yeah yes yes you know what he does he
pushes their buttons
ever so slightly and she explodes and
then everybody sees the explosion but
they don't see how it starts yeah but
I don't think it's an excuse someone can
push your buttons they're just not an
excuse to act no they're both sick
people because they both get off on it
you think they get off yeah because she
does the same to him he's still there
he's still there yeah I guess
that's how their relationship is they
will start off playing and then you know
like when when you're playing as a child
it's like someone's going to get hurt
stopped because someone's going to end
up crying and that's what normally
happens
that's crazy they said she was like a
successful track star before yeah she
was she was very good and then it's like
this relationship is this how she's a
borderline alcoholic she does she looks
you wouldn't recognize her from her
track days you tricked you today
well that day you called me a [__] can
y'all tell us what happened
let's stay on that day let's stay on
that day like what are you talking about
back and forth so yeah that day
I'm playing with the white dude I'm
playing with the white dude whatever
[__]
and I guess she felt some type of way
about
I don't know about him so she's like man
leave him alone
said what he said I thought he was
talking about me he kept saying oh yeah
I'm talking to the oven okay what are
you talking about rock have you ever I
Remember Have You Ever Had a sober day
shut the [__] up yes
oh my gosh oh my gosh
oh girl what are you doing oh my
goodness
you're not really talking to me
you know what happened what happened you
wouldn't you wouldn't have did none of
that [__] you're not really talking to
me
you're not really talking to me
I could drink liquor I could do it bro
well let's finish the story so the toxic
got over 60 000 over my body
weird [__] like but you're still talking
[__]
everybody if if I feel the way I feel I
feel the way I feel like if I feel
disrespected
you feel disrespected yeah he's my man
that's okay it's the same [__] that
will call me a [__] so what do you mean
what do you think what are you talking
about you do something what are you
talking about you do something [__]
it's not even that dude
I like your style
the avocado the guy
with the white shoes on the table he's
just as bad as old blueface whatever his
name is because all they're doing is
pushing their buttons
because he insulted her and she reacted
she reacted and now he's saying well
he doesn't like the way she reacted but
you just insulted her whereas
the other lady in the black
fantastic host my point of view I don't
know
if you say to someone I really think the
host insults if you say to me if I'm
having a drink and you say to me have
you ever had a sober day in your life
I'm going to react to that yeah but like
I I think like I just wouldn't be
offended yeah I mean if you're acting
like a drunk and someone says like are
you always this way it's kind of like
yeah you didn't say oh you're always his
way he said have you ever spent a sober
day right and that's what she said she
said the same thing no she said [__]
you're not talking to me you're not
talking and then he got upset because of
the way she spoke to him but she gave
him just the same energy
because I I had the same when I done the
show and I was drinking champagne and I
wasn't drunk I said what I had to say
and then somebody accused me of being
drunk and then I had the same reaction
what she did yeah but you don't think
she's drunk
being drunk today and making assumption
she uh he asked her a question and then
she answered it I'm thinking if you get
if you're on a podcast and you're and
she's acting clearly drunk okay she's
like this isn't this is it an assumption
it's based on behavior and if you can't
hold yourself together on a 5 million
follower podcast I'm gonna think you're
a drunk and on top of that if I've seen
video of after video after video after
video of you being drunk I'm I think
it's a fair question to say have you
ever had a sober day in your life they
only drunk together
he never asked her that they're normally
drunk together and the videos they're
normally drunk together
it would be a fair question for blueface
too but she was arguing I think that her
response was fine I think he she
answered his question correctly
I don't I don't I think that she's
acting nuts no she's acting I'm not
saying that her whole behavior is good
I'm saying that the way she responded to
what his statement or his question was
okay and look at the way all the
questions that he's been asking her
trying to push her buttons the lady of a
co-host of an interdiction and has been
professional about it not personal and
she's still got the same results out
yeah I just think I just think the way
she's acting is unprofessional and I've
been in situations where people like
maybe you're disrespectful but I just
think you should stay professional if
you know that so if you believe
someone's a drunk and you've got all
them millions of followers and he has
obviously he's seen a drunk before loads
of times why would you have on the show
and expect her to be sober if you know
she's a drunk that means that you want a
drunk on your show because you know
she's a drunk so don't have a drunk on
your show and then insult her for being
drunk because you know she's always
drunk so that question he shouldn't have
said because he's aware that's why he's
got her there otherwise if you know
you've got an alcoholic on your show
would you keep on feeding them alcohol
no exactly so no I'm not trying to and
he put and he passed her the drink he
gave it to her he could have said no
you're on my podcast you've had enough
which would be the responsible thing
especially as she's already said I might
be on my period or I might be pregnant
so he's there on a show giving somebody
who might be pregnant alcohol I mean I'm
not I'm not saying that he's acting 100
professional I'm just saying I don't
think her response is warranted and I
just and I just yeah I just think the
way she's acting is like that's trashy
to me but that's the couple they are
trashy couple yeah I know
it's a fight that [__] ain't Justified
straight up you know how to talk to your
man crazy don't do that women it's not a
woman
I understand I understand
wait look so if I could say
because I called you a [__] you just
can't listen to nobody I understand I
understand if you caught me a [__] I
should be able to call you a [__] back
however if you're still responsible for
your response to that and I don't think
hitting him with glass was the correct
response I'm glad she hit him with glass
yo yeah that's not even what happened
look my hand is cut up so that's what
happened and I can't use my good hands
you got to keep talking and if a [__]
like play me what do you mean they
wouldn't be great safe I'm about to be
quiet and I'm about to be painted as the
bad picture that's cool
let's finish the story
first getting warm that's just not even
talking about if I hit you first all
right so basically she felt some type of
work don't worry did I hit you back she
said you acting like that first I said
damn okay hit you first so uh she had
this little cut on her hand from weeks
prior she had to cut herself and I knew
that that was a sensitive spot for her
so I said hey watch your mouth and I
squeezed her in and she just turned up
instantly like
and so she started coming on to me and
so yeah that's how that happened so
actually coming on to me I'm like you
know deflecting obviously wrestling with
her next he will go to the next one she
realized she couldn't beat me she went
outside she went for a walk she came
back with a glass covering I kid you not
I locked the [__] sliding door
I'm like she could do some fried [__]
she went for a walk she came back with a
glass cup I locked the door on her shot
like opened the door
boom
she started coming close to me with that
glass I'm like oh I know she's gonna hit
me with this glass right I'm like um
so look what do you mean too much
attention why are you doing that I'm not
against you right now stop being like
that we're just not talking about this
interview that's usually cool
now you're just being like how because
obnoxious because you're trying to say I
started it like [__] like I hit you
first I didn't hit you first don't say
that I wish you knew that
means more than
what somebody did first or a second your
response
speaks for you okay what happens first
or second has nothing to do with you
your response is what just throws you
off the [__] did you hear them what
they say though did I say I hit you
first it's not even that did I hear what
they said though [__] what they said
yeah
exactly okay let's get the story stuff
okay instead of going what you're said
is
something did you realize what's
happening here he sent the story
and like you had the same response oh my
God she hit him with the glass but yeah
she's saying but I didn't hit you first
you know before we say equal lifts and
equal right just because somebody hits
you slightly and now he's saying it
doesn't matter who hit first or second
it all depends on your risk yeah if you
hit first
is there oh I was
pull up the video here first she
responded back she went away obviously
stronger so she hit him back with a
glass and now they're trying to make it
seem and all she wants them to say is
she hit second and she just responded
back she said she needs help if they're
saying what they're saying what are they
saying if we saying [__] what they
saying why are you saying what they
saying because we're interviewing with
them and and you was agreeing with the
same [__] we saying [__] what they
saying what you saying
so she came back with a cup yeah she
came back with the cup I'm like I know
she's nothing to do this open the door
start acting like she's gonna hit me
with the girl I'm like bro
if you hit me with this cup like it's
gonna go up like don't do that so I kind
of like turned to the side and I did
shoot the cut right at my head
boom
it went up I wanna I wanna I wanna speak
on something it's not even why we got
I'm not even talking about I'm not
talking about that can I speak some
money give me two seconds
beat us emotionally now they want to try
to fight us physically you can't beat us
physically but y'all knew what y'all
could do was beat us emotionally y'all
knew how to hit us where it really hurt
on the inside women don't even do that
no more it's immediately external bad
when I hurt you physically sure
and emotionally but they don't it's like
women have lost that sure this is what
it is it's that equality [__] just how
you you see how they agree oh if you
call me a [__] I should be able to call
you a [__] too
how is that so if you have a vagina we
were taught to take off the people they
call us [__] right they're not
they're not their friends
I kind of see what they're saying though
like when you call I mean and not for me
personally but like when you call
someone like it's a different
connotation if you call a guy versus a
girl you don't think
I've never had nobody call me a picture
the Americans the women call each other
[__] yeah and it's fine yeah so I
think every man calls you a [__] she
means it
I don't think any mentioned that they'll
say like that's I don't think it's right
I'm just saying they'll be like oh
that's my bit like
I've never had that I mean it's an
American I have it either it's just like
I think it's an American thing yeah but
he actually called a [__]
I know I think if you're with someone
you wouldn't if somebody call me [__]
they don't like me and if you do if you
are going to call your man [__] and
it's something that used to have as a
joke then that being private not in
public double standard
that's just what it is
listening there's plenty of those that
work in favor of you guys right yes such
as dealing with women such as hitting a
man such as no I don't agree with
hitting the [__]
regardless if you hit me or if you hit
me it's gonna be looked at as like a
joke if I hit her people are gonna
really feel like well I'm really
aggressor you're the abuser so I've said
before that I have an issue you know
just like you said it's a flawed you
guys have way more of those than your
favor yeah so why can't why you can't
take one
y'all have so many
people agree with what what happened but
I understand what she trying to say do I
agree with her calling you a [__] no I
get what she's saying too but in closing
of that I like that but I I don't agree
in closing of that we were taught that
when you get called a [__] say it this
is the thing if we if we if we continue
the pattern with a guy I just took twice
neither of them should be calling each
other like I just that's part of their
vocabulary towards each other this is
just crazy oh my God this is at some
point we got I can't even imagine being
in a relationship like this
can you imagine being in a relationship
like that and the thing is is that she
was so slim and sexy and everything in
her day when she was running now she's
got rolls and rolls
how to beat a person and say let's stop
it lay down you got to be submissive I
know your mama taught you that like hey
if you call somebody a [__] you just
got to be prepared for what comes after
that people taught me that [__] straight
up you call a grown ass man you call a
grown ass man a [__]
by the time
so this day that we fought with this cup
she called me a [__] first ask her
about what what made her call me that
because I felt like play with like
whatever how so what I said I don't
really just tell me don't play with me
my [__] she don't remember tell him
like that now don't play with me before
we really get into it don't play with me
I'm gonna trip I could feel that we're
talking and [__] and in a way you
talking is like weird like he's just
disrespecting me so I'm like yo why are
you being a [__] oh
oh yeah and I'm like
if I call you a [__] you should be able
to call me my Mac right
is that weight don't don't think for a
woman right now
that's what she said right without I
think without repercussion yet okay so
if I don't call you a [__] person you
call me one first that's wrong
when you watch them on their chick well
whatever they do when they do their book
calls [__] is part of the vocabulary
now they just agreed she didn't actually
call him a [__] she said why are you
acting like a [__] there's a difference
foreign
[Music]
he's saying like is it cool when he says
you're my [__]
I don't know
see I feel like it should be at the it
should be unless you've got four legs
you shouldn't be called [__] can we
just call Ellie a [__]
she's a [__] yeah
he's a [__] are you cool with him why
did you get saying my [__] why not I
don't know I didn't call you [__] why
not I shouldn't have I got mad at it if
I didn't call you the whole trip you
were calling me a [__] we're not
talking about any other time though I'm
saying well you're mad when it's you
I was upset with you I called you a
[__] so why did you why did you hit him
with a cup what why did you hit him with
a cup do you mean why did I hit him with
a cup that's it why are you leaving
without it because you ain't even got
the truth on you that's why you repeated
it you think I don't know bro
I'm telling you are you good as hell
whoa I'm telling you look do that baby
that type of [__] I'm listening
correct couple drinks after that you're
gonna be like
you're not even gonna think about it no
cause you were repeating you was like
this why did I hit him with a cup I
thought you was gonna come off because
such and such and such
like yeah I'm saying we're fighting
something something so different your
hand was [__] up he said your hand was
injured yeah so yeah I hit him with a
cup what's up what are you saying that's
very violent okay just re-injure your
hair with a cup what's up so let's get
violent violent let's get back I thought
you love him I love him one day you
actually heard him and he's not here
with us no more can I can I ask you a
question
can I ask you a question so it's the
life we chose no I said that's bad
I'm saying the mentality
no but are you supposed to sit there and
always try to be the proof man [__] you
don't have to prove everything there's
nothing wrong
because I'm I have a right to express
myself [__] with a cup I'm getting hit
oh my God that's expressing good Lord
I can only imagine with [__] like she
feels like this
right now it's to the progress you have
to contest that you feel me
not a stranger I'm saying it's to the
point where it's like as a man
what's going on shut up you don't feel
like you have to go there
that blue face he's an enabler
because about a few minutes earlier he
said um yeah we're not talking about
fighting give her a couple of drinks
after that
all right so tell us straight up don't
be like you guys tell us straight up
well let's get to the next subject can
we get can we go
yeah
you've got free so-called responsible
adults on there one alcoholic
they've been feeding the alcohol nah
they know she's an alcoholic they're
pushing all their buttons they've
allowed her to walk off grab the whole
bottle of brandy first she did she was
coming yeah she's got a whole body
straight in between her legs so cognac
what is she why would she because she's
she's in alcoholic she just drowns out
everything with alcohol
I still respect you reaction
go ahead what do you want to say what do
you want to say right now
just trying to disrespect her nobody
disrespect you one timing what is it
what is it the [__] the cups we're
talking about the cups
my Hennessy I'm talking what I'm saying
listen I would love for her to just be
honest
I'm coming right coming let's go
nobody's coming like that no we're
keeping all this you're the only person
coming like all right I have a question
I ain't saying erase it I said run that
[__] back I have a question wrong what I
mean not boy no because I'm defensive
right now you don't have to be the
person we listening
everything we're talking about that
glass cup going through your head you're
trying to say
you trying to say you wanna act like you
give a [__] you're trying
to guess like me just
just let me talk to myself you saying
what you're saying you're saying okay I
disrespected you
Wham I had no what reason the disrespect
you yeah
how what was the reason
what do you mean if anybody disrespects
whatever you said
listening
somebody disrespect me I could tell you
exactly what they said how they said it
which part I didn't like and what
trigger yeah what happened right it's
like all right if I feel disrespect I'm
like um and I say what I say like all
right you've been a [__]
he didn't take it like he how I said it
he like oh you call me a [__]
yeah what you mean you call me a [__]
all the time when I feel when you feel
like I'm a [__] you feel like I'm a
[__] so you gonna say it so why can't I
say you a [__] because I feel like
you're a [__] like straight up yeah you
feel like it hurts your feelings
and play with you right and you feel
like a [__] she was hurt and I say
you're a [__] and then I'm like okay
you say you always tell me when I'm a
[__] why can't I tell you when you're a
[__] okay that's weird listening wait
hold on Gina you can tell me that bro
you need to say oh you need to remember
word from word I don't bro cause the
ones think about me one thing about
trauma yeah
one thing about trauma one thing about
[__] that play with me
what do you mean I don't I I that's what
I asked earlier
but the trauma I'm talking about the
situation you were talking about you're
trying to like change the subject and
play with me because I'm drunk I'm not
drunk
[Music]
good night
listen to what I'm saying dissecting it
and then picking her part of her truth
exactly I feel like this one right here
she just stop saying this one right here
talk to me look at me I'm right I'm
right here I'm [__] right here I'm
right here with you stop playing with me
we're Sharp
I love you you're just talking and short
and you trying to like isolate me from
that conversation I love you I'm sorry
if you want me to be the [__] you're
talking about when you talking to talk
about I'll be that [__]
you said any other [__]
like what I'll be cool and I'll be quiet
speak for myself I'll be cool and I'll
be quiet like okay I'll be cool I'll be
quiet why are you still talking because
I'm talking to you man what are you
talking about because Daddy I'm talking
to you
I'm talking to you how I feel
so let's let's bring things out again
like that rock I have a question for you
we're trying to get some questions here
sweetie for real for real I don't care I
don't look bad okay I look like myself
Rock I have a question for you the [__]
they asking hard questions that nobody
never asked and this is how I'm
answering them straight up if you don't
want to be with me
when she said her asking some hard-ass
questions
we're trying here baby but well I have
another hard question
why not
come on
hey come on I'm gonna step out and let
y'all do the new part come on
[Music]
pick one I got Security in here y'all
better car hey please get some help with
that please thank you
to win them they're cool yeah hey please
Jay fixer
outside
okay it's tone around here
you're a good man
sick
[Music]
we know you came with him sweetie but
right now it's just time to isolate that
a little bit
Joshua everything under control
everything good okay
we're fine is it Mike's going to pick
that up or can we are the mics going to
pick that up or can we finish
[Music]
um
no you good blue sit down blue you come
sit down when you're ready
yeah we'll just turn that one off please
yeah please turn that one off right
there
I don't speak for you
she gonna learn the hard way church one
day she actually got a good dude in her
life because I I I don't speak I don't
speak for you I don't speak for you
right that's what you said the whole
interview I don't speak for you so now
you're cut like bro close the blinds bro
close the blinds take her outside if you
got to
come here
there it is
bro take her outside
no I know you can't but they can't yeah
hey can we please get her outside take
her outside please pick her up buy her
eggs can you please help please Tom can
you please help assess the situation
please
come here
there ain't nobody trying to grab your
woman ever like trying to people trying
to be respectful you know but if I do
what I we ain't gonna let you know cause
you're not catching no cases exactly
you're not doing any of that that's not
what we have you here for and I hey I'm
proud of you for sitting back and really
just taking care of your business she'll
be at home later on you'll still be able
to talk and assess the situation but
right now yeah I just think it's best
that it just
she off that Hennessy man
we'll talk about it there's nothing to
talk like all that's gonna do is add
fuel to the [__] fire no no okay
that is so disgusting they do that all
the time to it that's disgusting they
should just cut her loose and just
forget about it but that's disgusting
because maybe you didn't understand but
he said oh that's why the other [__]
when I tell them to shut up they just
shut up and that's what she was saying
well while you're talking about other
[__] when I'm with you look at me if
you want me to be like that
and you want me to shut up just tell me
I will shut up and that's what she's
saying you two are talking about this
and cutting me out of it that's what got
her annoyed
so they're always doing that this is
what happens they get her drunk
then she freaks out and then they kick
her off as if it's all down to her when
there's free enablers there because all
they're doing is letting her drink
alcohol and I drink alcohol if you're a
man and you've got a cup and you know
that your woman's drunk there is no way
you're gonna let a woman to take it out
of your house it's like when you say
that though it's almost like if a dude
did the same thing would you say that
like if it's an alcoholic I'd say the
same thing because you don't enable an
alcoholic you do not give an alcoholic
alcohol and don't expect them to react
that's like saying oh I've got a
crackhead on the show but you know it's
okay because I'm gonna give them crack
you wouldn't do it so you wouldn't give
an alcoholic alcohol and a menu from a
start because before that started she
was inebriated and then he gave he gave
her she drunk half because what they
normally do is share it she gave her I'm
not saying there's no part to play like
on the other people it's just like I
just think that's crazy like I just
think I'm so crazy crazy but she's drunk
so she will like crazy that's what I'm
trying to say you're not going to act in
your right mind drunk
yeah but there's levels there's people
that can get drunk and they're fine no
but she's not one of them that's why
they do it they can both drink the same
thing and she will end up drunk women
will tend to get drunk quicker than men
yeah at all but they said that she was
drunk and then they gave her alcohol and
then he allowed her to take it from his
hand because he's such a man that you're
not gonna how can I get a cup from you
unless you want me to have it and then
they allowed her she was asking for the
drink they got her the drink which I
already said previously that you're
drunk so why would you give her a drink
then why would you allow her to walk off
pick up the alcohol then come back do
you know it's the person at the side
kind of had the right idea and slipped
the bottle away and put water there
instead yeah you know they had the right
idea because they thought no but then
she still managed to take a men's drink
I just think that she needs help this is
um they're right what they said in the
beginning like um was it Whitney and and
Bobby and that's how I just feel like
they should not I feel they should be
together they should just focus on their
music
like or something separately you know
but if you guys want to come on the show
and talk about your relationship I'm
more than willing to do it sober
yeah sober
no alcohol no alcohol here it'll be
banned alcohol free I'd like to be there
as well we'll see
I've got your back girl you'll see we'll
see
um yeah I just think that that is crazy
I just can't I just can't imagine being
that old and acting like that like
they're in their 20s but you can't
imagine being an alcoholic either
no I could I have yeah no I really could
no I mean imagine it and being it is
totally different I think I've never
drank before but like I just made
decisions to not like being an alcoholic
is totally different to just being drunk
every now and again yeah I know I mean I
have a lot of extended family that's all
cool yeah but it all comes down to their
own damn choices like it's just but once
you once you're a full-blown alcoholic
then you wouldn't give an alcohol
alcoholic alcohol no I wouldn't and
that's what I mean is that he's got
enough money that everybody wanted to
the same way how you can get security to
take her out he can get security to put
us somewhere to dry her out he's got
enough money with all the jury and I'm
sure a couple of those wings and get her
into rehab
yeah that's true you're not gonna make
money off of her sober so you think he's
just trying to make money off of her I
think that's the way they generate their
money
because if they were um
all right then if the um
you've had two couple guests on the show
that I don't go with they was taught
normally and they taught sense it
wouldn't be the same and that's what
people like about that couple they like
the fireworks yeah I mean it's
entertaining for sure it gives us stuff
to react so it makes me feel sick and
nauseous I hate you did I give you an
aneurysm today oh I think it was
disgusting all right I just picked
myself that poor girl put us somewhere
let her dry out you know you know get
back to him again put around yeah before
the show tonight yeah you're right we're
doing a show tonight
um destiny is going to be on Auntie's
gonna be on um King riches is going to
be on
um Esther is going to be on
um yeah so guys tune in tonight 8 30
right blessing yeah 8 30. like the video
on your way out subscribe to the channel
and we'll talk to you next time